in this course you will learn how to
integrate a react application with a.net
API component Gavin Lon teaches this
course Gavin is a freako camp team
member and one of the creators of our
popular full react course
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long
in this video we are going to build a
basic react front end that queries a web
API component written in C sharp so by
going through this video you'll learn
one of the easiest ways to create a
react application that leverages a.net
web API component
we'll code this application using visual
studio 2022 Community Edition which can
be downloaded free of charge
I've included a link in the description
of this video that points to where you
are able to download visual studio 2022
Community Edition for both Windows and
Mac OS platforms the function of this
basic application enables users to rank
items by dragging and dropping the
relevant items for example well-known
movies
onto a grid each cell in the ranking
grid denotes a ranking value
so basically the item that has been
dragged to the top left ranking cell is
ranked number one
the item to the immediate right of the
top left ranking cell denotes a ranking
value of two and so on
the worst possible ranking is 16.
denoted by the cell in the bottom right
cell of the ranking grid
this is of course not an original app
but I thought this would be a great way
to demonstrate writing a basic react
front end that leverages a web API
component
that runs on.net 6. okay so as you can
see I got myself a green screen
the only problem that I can think of
about having a green screen is that you
run the risk of getting carried away
okay so I'm glad I got that out of my
system let's get into this video
let's fire up visual studio 2022
the project template that we want to use
for this project is named asp.net core
with react.js
so let's select this item and press the
next button
let's name our project ranking app
let's press the next button
as you can see we are going to build
the.net part of this application on.net
6. let's press the create button
great let's take a brief look at the
project structure that has been
automatically generated for US based on
the project template that we have chosen
to access the client-side code we can
open the client app folder here
then we can look at the react components
that have been automatically generated
within the SRC slash components folder
we have the counter component the fetch
data component and the home component
then to look at the auto-generated
service site.net code we can open the
controllers folder here
we have the weather forecast controller
class
which contains code for a.net web API
component
if we look here we have the get action
method that represents the get verb
pertaining to a HTTP get request
this method returns an array containing
made-up weather forecast related data
this code has been generated for us
through the use of the relevant project
template to give us an example of how
the interaction between the front-end
react code and the.net backend web API
code can be implemented in our project
the react client component named fetch
data calls the weather forecast.net web
API component and displays the weather
forecast data returned from the get
request to the browser the counter
component demonstrates basic react
functionality
but when we click the fetch data menu
option
the code within the fetch data react
component is invoked and calls the
weather forecast
server-side.net web API component and
displays the data that is returned as an
array to the client on the user's
browser
you can see that the asp.net core with
react.js project template automatically
generates code for us to facilitate the
integration of a.net web API component
with the client-side code implemented
using react.js
so let's create a folder here named
models
let's add a c-sharp class to the models
folder and let's name our class item
model
in this video we are going to develop a
basic application that enables a user to
rank movies and albums we'll first
create the code whereby a user can use
our application to rank a collection of
movies
but we want our model class to be
generic so the item model class can also
be used to represent for example albums
or other types of items we want users to
be able to rank using our application
so the item model class can represent
any type of item that we may wish to
integrate into our application so this
helps our application to be extensible
let's include an ID Auto implemented
property of type integer let's include a
string property named title
let's include an integer property named
image ID each item will have an
Associated image our application will
contain a collection of images that are
uniquely identifiable so each item will
be associated with one specific image an
item has a one-to-one relationship with
an image in the system you'll clearly
see how this works as we progress with
the creation of this application let's
include an integer property named
ranking
this property represents the ranking
value that a user can assign to a
particular item let's include an item
type property of type integer in this
application we are going to allow for
the user to rank a collection of movies
as well as albums
so we are going to assign movies the
item type identifier value of one and
albums the item type identifier value of
2. so item types have a one-to-many
relationship with the items in our
system this will be clarified as we
progress with the development of the
application
so let's create our controller class
within the controllers folder let's add
a class and name it item controller this
class will contain an action method that
will service HTTP get requests from
clients when a valid request is made to
the relevant get action method the
action method will query a collection of
items and return an array of items for a
specific item type to the appropriate
react client component so for example
if a client requests an array of items
that have an item type of one
an array of items representative of
movies will be returned to the client so
to make our class a controller class
let's first make our item control across
inherit from the controller Base Class
let's press Ctrl period and bring in the
microsoft.asp.netcore.mvc namespace the
next step in making our class controller
class is to decorate the item controller
class with the API controller attribute
in order to declare appropriate routing
information for our controller class
let's appropriately decorate our item
controller class with the root attribute
let's pass in the text controller
wrapped in square brackets as an
argument to the Constructor of the root
attribute
so I want to keep the server-side web
API component code really basic because
the focus of this tutorial
is how to easily Implement interaction
functionality between a react client and
server-side web API code implemented
using.net
so for the sake of this basic example we
are going to implement the data on the
server side as a static collection
rather than for example storing the
relevant data in a SQL Server database
in a database table if this was a real
world application of course we'd want to
persist the relevant data and for
example a relational database storage
facility black SQL server or perhaps a
nosql storage facility like mongodb
we could then use for example Entity
framework core to interact with
whichever storage facility we have
chosen
So within our item controller class
let's create a private static read-only
Eye enumerable collection that is
strongly typed with our user-defined
type item model
let's name our collection items note
that rather than follow me here tapping
away at the keyboard to declare and
populate our items collection you can
copy the relevant code from this URL
that points to an appropriate GitHub
webpage
so you can see here we have in our
collection references to well-known
movies The Godfather Highlander
Highlander 2 The Last of the Mohicans
Police Academy 6.
rear window Road House
the Shawshank Redemption Star Trek 4 the
return home and Superman 4.
so this get action method accepts an
argument of type integer named item type
let's create a link query that queries
our collection of items in order to
filter the items collection based on the
item type value passed in from the code
that we'll write a bit later within a
react component note that at the moment
the items in our collection denote
movies so only one type of item is
currently stored within our collection
later on we'll extend our code whereby
albums will be stored within this
collection
so in order to tell.net as it were that
this get method pertains to a HTTP get
request we must decorate our get action
method with the HTTP get attribute we
must also pass in this text denoting
that an argument of type int must be
passed as an argument when the relevant
get request is made from the client
let's create a react component
let's name this file rankitems.js
for those of you who wish to learn the
basics of react or wish to refresh your
knowledge I've recently contributed to a
project-based react for beginners course
for freecodecamp.org I've included a
link to this course Below in the
description of this video
I'm really happy to have contributed to
this course along with two other
instructors John smilga and sanjif Theo
garajan
John and Sanjeev are both excellent
instructors and very well known I've
included links to their YouTube channels
Below in the description of this video
let's write the code to import the use
statehook and the use effect hook into
our rank items component
let's create a basic structure for our
functional component
let's write the code to return some
basic jsx code from our component
let's write code to implement the use
State hook so that react can track the
state of the items collection returned
from the server through the code that we
have just implemented for our item
controller class
so you can see here we have a
destructured array returned from the use
statehook the first variable returned
pertains to the items collection data
that will be initially retrieved from
our server-side code and the second
variable pertains to a function that can
be used in our react component to change
the state of the item's variable
we'll appropriately implement the code
to change the state of the items array
in just a bit
note that at the moment we are setting
the items array to an empty array by
default this is denoted by the empty
square brackets we are currently passing
in as an argument to the use State hook
here
so when our rank items component first
loads we want our codes to call the
appropriate web API component in order
to retrieve the relevant items
collection data from the server and then
we want our code to change the state of
the items array
we are able to implement code that
executes when our component first loads
by using the use effect hook in a
specific way
to achieve this we need to pass a
function as the first arguments to the
use effect hook and pass empty square
brackets denoting an empty array as the
second argument to the use effect hook
let's write code for an anonymous
function that we are passing as an
arguments to the first parameter of the
use effect hook
so we want our code to return a
collection of movie data from our web
API component
we can use javascript's fetch method to
make an appropriate HTTP get request to
the relevant endpoint
we need to pass a value denoting the
item type value to the server
in the rules of our application a value
of 1 for the item type argument means we
want to return a collection containing
data for movies
a value of 2 for the item type argument
means that we want the collection to
contain data for a collection of albums
we haven't yet added the data to our
server-side code for the collection of
albums but we'll start by testing the
code for retrieving a collection of
movie data so the data type variable on
the client has been initialized to one
which means the relevant web API
server-side code should return a
collection of items with an item type of
one movie data the data is returned in
Json format if our code gets to this
point and a valid collection of movie
data has been successfully returned from
our web API component we can use the set
items function to change the state of
our items variable when a variable
status tracked through the use of the
use statehook and its status changed
this means that the state of the
component has changed when the state of
a react component changes the react
component is re-rendered
so the code within the returned jsx code
is transpiled into code that a web
browser understands before it is
re-rendered inside the user's browser
window the code is appropriately
re-rendered really fast which is what
makes react such a great choice for
implementing user interactive front-end
code for the web
so we have now created basic code for
our rank items component that retrieves
appropriate data from the server then
changes the state of our component which
results in our component being
appropriately re-rendered the next step
is to appropriately modify the app
root.js file let's open the approots.js
file
let's modify the app Roots array in
order to add a new route that points to
our rank items component as it were
we must of course also write code to
import the rank items component into our
approot component
great
so we have told react as it were about
how to access the rank items component
through the code that we have just
written within the app Roots component
the next step is to include the relevant
link within the nav menu component
to provide a way for the user to
navigate to the rank items component as
it were
let's open the file named navmenu.js
let's appropriately include a nav item
element and include a nav link child
element within the nav item parent
element
let's ensure that the path that we have
appropriately included for the rank
items component within the app Roots
array is appropriately included within
our new nav link element
we can do this by appropriately
assigning the relevant path to the rank
items component to the two property of
the nav link element
let's run our code and test whether we
can invoke the rank items component by
clicking the appropriate navigation link
that we have just created
okay so why has that not worked
by using the asp.net core with react.js
project template to create our project
code has been automatically included
within our project to make the
interaction between the react client
code and the server-side.net code easy
for us to implement
so all we need to do is tell our client
react code as it were about our
server-side controller class and we can
do this by simply including a reference
to item our item controller class in the
context array like this
you can see here by default the context
array includes an item denoting the
weather forecast controller class that
is used by the fetch data react
component to retrieve weather forecast
data from the server that can then be
rendered through the fetch data
component
so we can include a new entry into the
context array that tells our client-side
code as it were about the items
controller code on the server
let's run the code
and you can see that our break point has
been hit within the get action method
within the item controller class
excellent our rank items react component
is now successfully communicating as it
were with the appropriate server-side
web API code
and each movie title is rendered to the
screen when our rank items component is
re-rendered after the movie data is
successfully retrieved from the server
and the set items client-side function
is called to appropriately update the
items array with the movie data
retrieved from the server this of course
changes the state of the rank items
component and the relevant front-end
code is appropriately re-rendered to the
browser
excellent
so if our code was retrieving a large
amount of data from the server it would
be a good idea to show a loading
indicator to the user while the data is
being delivered from the server to the
client
providing such status information to the
user provides a better ux user
experience so to simulate that a large
amount of data is being sent from server
to client let's create an artificial
delay on the server like this
so you can see here that an empty array
is currently set by default in the
relevant use State hook
so of course the array will never be
null
so in the return code here
instead of checking for a null value
let's check the number of items in the
array so while the array is empty I.E
has not yet been brought down from the
server we want a loading indicator to be
displayed to the user
great
so instead of just displaying the movie
titles to the user's browser we want the
poster images for each of the movies to
be displayed in a list
to do this let's first create a new
react component that has the
responsibility of importing Movie images
into our application
let's name the relevant react component
with the images.js
before we write the code for this
component let's create a folder within
the SRC folder named images
I've prepared the movie images for our
application and they can be downloaded
from this location on GitHub
so let's create a folder within the
images folder named movies
and let's ensure that the images that we
have downloaded from the relevant GitHub
repository resides within this movies
folder
let's write the code to import the
images from the movies folder
we can do this by including the
appropriate import statements at the top
of our movie images.js react component
like this
if you like this video please give this
video a thumbs up and please feel free
to share this video with anyone you feel
May benefit from its content
please also consider subscribing to the
channel and hit the Bell icon so that
you'll be notified of future content
let's create an array to store these
imported images
then let's write the code to export our
array so that other components can use
the array
within the div element that will wrap
the list of movie images that we want
displayed from within the rank items
component let's reference a CSS class
that we'll write in just a bit named
items Dash not Dash ranked
then let's write the jsx code to Output
each of the images to the screen from
within our rank items component
note that each item that our code
traverses has a property named image ID
which corresponds to an ID property of
an object stored in the movie image
error array let's write code that uses
the JavaScript find method to find the
appropriate image for each item
great but the images are of course too
big so we must style our images
appropriately let's first create a div
container element for each of the
relevant image elements
let's include a reference to our CSS
class for each of our div container
elements let's call our CSS class
unranked-cell
let's open the custom.css file and
create the appropriate styling code
so firstly let's create the appropriate
CSS code for the items Dash not Dash
ranked class
let's then create the appropriate CSS
code for the unranked Dash cell clause
and let's also create the appropriate
CSS code for the IMG elements that are
housed within the div container elements
that reference the unranked Dash cell
CSS class
excellent and we are now presented with
a list of movie images each of these
images denotes an unranked movie item
so we have now created the functionality
for displaying the movies we want our
users to rank in a list
so the way in which we want our users to
rank the items is by dragging the
relevant images onto a grid
the position to where the user drags an
image will result in a unique ranking
value that corresponds to each cell
within the ranking grid being allocated
to the relevant item I.E the dragged
image item which represents a movie so
for example when a user drags the image
representing the movie The Godfather to
the top left position in the grid the
ranking grid this means that the item is
ranked number one so the item's ranking
value is one
so each cell in the ranking grid denotes
a ranking value
except for the cells in the leftmost
column these cells are used for labeling
purposes
so each cell in the ranking grid denotes
a ranking value
the ranking value is positioned for each
ranking cell progressing from left to
right and top to bottom by a value of 1
from 1 to 16. so the top left item
denotes a ranking value of one the item
to the immediate right of the cell that
denotes a ranking value of one denotes a
value of 2 and the bottom right item
denotes a ranking value of 16. so our UI
will give the user a great ux where the
user can simply drag the image
representing an unranked item to the
chosen position on the ranking Grid in
order to allocate an appropriate ranking
value to the relevant item
a ranking value of 1 denotes the most
highly ranked item and a ranking value
of 16 denotes the lowest possible
ranking value
great so let's create a react component
responsible for outputting a grid to the
screen that will denote our ranking grid
let's create a component named ranking
grid.js
let's first create the basic structure
for a react functional component
so we are using de-structuring here for
the props that the rank items component
will pass down to our ranking grid
component the rank items component is
the parent component of the ranking grid
child component
so here the items array and the image
array are passed down as props to our
ranking grid component so we are going
to create the code for the Grid in this
component dynamically
through appropriately coded JavaScript
methods what I mean by this will become
clearer as we develop the code for this
component
so firstly let's declare five JavaScript
arrays
these arrays will be used to build
relevant jsx code that can be outputted
from our component
the ranking grid array will store an
array of elements that make up the
entire ranking grid the cell collection
top array will store the elements that
represent the top row in the ranking
grid the cell collection middle array
will store the elements that represent
the middle row in the ranking grid the
cell collection bottom array will store
the elements that represent the second
most bottom row in the ranking grid the
cell collection worst array will store
the elements that represent the very
bottom where all the worst ranked items
will reside as it were after being
ranked by the user
let's create the code to return the
relevant jsx code
let's write codes to call a JavaScript
method named create ranking grid that is
responsible for outputting the jsx code
for our ranking grid
in the create ranking grid method a call
to a method that we have not yet written
is made named create cells for rows this
code is returning the returned value
from a method that we'll write next
named create rows for grid
so let's work backwards as it were and
create the code for the create rows for
grid method
so you can see that this code simply
pushes jsx elements
into a JavaScript array the first item
in the array represents the top row for
the ranking grid the second item in the
array represents the middle row in the
ranking grid the third item in the array
represents the second to bottom row in
the ranking grid the fourth item in the
array represents the very bottom row and
the ranking grid
let's create the code for the method
named create cells for rows
so here our code is looping four times
IE one for each row in the ranking grid
within the loop a call to a method named
create cells for row is made
this method is responsible for creating
each cell for a particular row
let's create the code for the create
cells for row method
so each row will contain five cells so
let's create code to Loop five times
each iteration of the loop creates a
cell for the relevant row
the first cell in each row does not have
a corresponding ranking value and is
used to label the relevant row this
means we must avoid assigning a ranking
value to cells used for labeling
purposes
let's create an if else if ladder as it
were to assign relevant values for each
row
then let's write code to appropriately
call a method that we'll write next
named push cell markup to error
let's create the push sell markup to our
method
so the code for this method
appropriately populates the cell arrays
that we declared earlier on at the top
of our code
so if the rank num variable is greater
than zero we know the cell pertains to a
cell that denotes a ranking position in
the grid
if the value of the rank num variable is
not greater than zero this means that
the cell is used for labeling purposes
and must not be assigned a ranking
number
so the markup for a cell that is used
for labeling purposes is different to a
cell that is used for ranking purposes
you can see that a cell used for ranking
purposes has an ID property that is
assigned a value with the rank literal
text followed by a dash prefix
and this is followed by the cell's
ranking value
this is how our code will know as it
were how to rank an item with an
appropriate ranking value once the item
has been dragged and dropped into the
relevant ranking cell on the ranking
grid
so let's open the rank items react
component
and write code to import the ranking
grid component into the rank items
component
let's include the code to call the
ranking grid component from within the
code responsible for outputting UI
related code from the rank items
component
note that we are passing down the
appropriate prop values to the ranking
grid component here
let's run the code
great but in order for the ranking grid
to display appropriately we must include
the appropriate CSS code within the
custom.css file so let's do that
great and that is starting to look
pretty good let's add code to our
custom.css code so that the output of
our components aligned centrally on the
horizontal axis
great
so at this point
we have a list of items that the user
can rank
we have also created the functionality
for the ranking grid
the user ranks an item by dragging and
dropping an item onto the appropriate
cell on the ranking grid each cell with
the exception of the cells used for
labeling each row in the ranking grid
serves as a ranking position
so if a user drags an item onto the top
left-hand ranking cell
that item's ranking value will be 1. if
the user drags an item to the immediate
right adjacent top left hand ranking
cell the relevant item's ranking value
will be assigned a value of 2 and so on
the bottom right cell and the ranking
grid denotes a ranking value of 16. okay
so we want to provide the user with a
great user experience so drag and drop
functionality will provide the user with
an easy and fun way to rank the relevant
items so let's create a code to
facilitate this functionality note that
the code we are about to create
unfortunately will not work for touch
screens I.E a user will not be able to
drag the relevant item by touching the
item on the screen and then dragging the
item
we'll look at how to create drag and
drop functionality using a touchscreen
device in an upcoming tutorial
so the functionality we are providing
here allows the user to select the item
with the user's Mouse pointer and to
drag the item by moving the mouse
Pointer while keeping the left Mouse
button suppressed and dropping the item
into the desired cell by dropping the
item at the desired location which is
done by releasing the left Mouse button
when the mouse pointer is hovered over
the relevant ranking cell
so to achieve the desired drag and drop
functionality let's first create a
method named drag
the code for this method is just one
simple line of code this line of code
simply stores the ID value of the item
that is being dragged
we'll look at how we are able to
retrieve this value in just a bit when
we discuss the method responsible for
the drop functionality okay let's create
a function named allow drop so in this
method our code EV dot prevent default
indicates that the default event that
would ordinarily be fired should be
canceled for the Target element so with
this code we are indicating that we are
overriding the default Behavior here
so let's write the event handler
function for the drop method
let's name the method drop
so firstly we are writing code to cancel
the default event our code then
references the target element I.E the
element where we wish to drop the
dragged element so if an image element
already exists as a child element within
the target element I.E where we are
attempting to drop an item we want to
disallow this action so if the user is
attempting to drop an item onto an
already existing
image element we want code to execute in
this case to return control back to the
calling code without executing any
further code in our drop method so let's
appropriately include return false here
then let's also check to see if the
target element contains any child
elements we only want the drop
functionality to be performed
successfully if the target element does
not contain any child elements
so for example this logic prevents the
user from dragging an element over an
already existing image in the relevant
ranking cell
if the target element does not contain
any child elements we want code to fire
that will cause the relevant item in the
items array to be changed accordingly so
we want the ranking property of the
relevant item to be changed to the
ranking value denoted by the cell into
which the user is dropping the relevant
item we are managing State for the items
array by appropriately using the use
State hook
so the change in value of the ranking
property of the relevant item will then
trigger our rank items components to be
re-rendered which means the image
element that the user has dragged onto
the ranking grid will remain in the
appropriate cell on the ranking grid
so once the code has run
to change the item's ranking property
accordingly
we must use the set items method to set
the state of the items array like this
as discussed the execution of this line
of code will trigger the ranking items
component to re-render
so let's include code within the rank
items return section of the component to
pass down references to the methods that
we have just created as props to the
ranking grid component
thank you
let's appropriately wire up the relevant
drag and drop methods to the cells that
represent a ranking position on the
ranking grid
let's include code that adds the
relevant image as a child element within
the target cell the image represents an
item that has its ranking property set
to the ranking value denoted by the
appropriate grid cell I.E the target
cell within the ranking grid
remember of course each cell represents
a ranking value from 1 to 16.
let's open the ranking items JS file and
include the relevant drag functionality
for the image elements that represent
items that the user can Rank by dragging
and dropping the items to an appropriate
position on the ranking grid
so let's test the code
okay so that did work but clearly the
IMG element is way too large within the
relevant ranking cell
so let's ensure that we include the
appropriate styling code within the
custom.css file so that the image
element takes up 100 of the height and
100 of the width of its parent cell
within the ranking grid
let's try that again
great
but when we drag and drop an item from
the item list onto the ranking grid we
want the relevant item to disappear from
the item list denoting that the relevant
item has been ranked it's not currently
doing this so we can achieve what we
want here by simply including an if
condition that checks that only unranked
items are included within the item list
here
all ranked items should appear within
the ranking grid so our if condition
checks the ranking property for each
item
if the checked item has a ranking value
that is greater than zero then it should
appear in the ranking grid and not the
item list conversely If an item has a
ranking property with a value of zero it
should be included within the item list
and not appear in the ranking grid
so of course one of the great things
about modern front-end Technologies like
react Blazer or angular is that we are
easily able to neatly wrap our code in
components
I can see within the rank items
component an opportunity to further
rationalize our code so let's create two
more components from the code
that we currently have within The Return
part of our rank items component
so we can abstract the rendering
functionality for each item in our items
list within its own component we can
also abstract the code that traverses
each item within the item array into its
own component so let's create a
component named item that denotes an
item within the items array
let's create a component named item
collection
that is responsible for traversing each
item in the items array let's write code
to import the item component into the
item collection component
let's write code that traverses each
item in the item array in order to
appropriately display each item in the
user's browser
let's write code to import the item
collection component into the rank items
component
and let's write code to call the item
collection component from within The
Return part of our rank items component
so we have now provided functionality so
that a user can rank a set of movies by
dragging an image from a list of items
to a position on a grid that we can
refer to as the ranking grid so we have
facilitated a drag and drop mechanism
for the user that can be utilized to
rank the items in the items list so we
are able to rank movies at the moment
what if we wanted to extend the
functionality of our application to
enable the ranking of other items for
example albums
so we are able to easily extend our
application so that a user can rank
other types of items because we have
written our code in such a way that it
is extensible we can reuse our
components for the purpose of ranking
other item types so let's prove this and
write code so that a user can rank
albums
let's first open the item controller
class
and includes these well-known albums
that we'd like the user to rank
I've selected a group of well-known
albums for this example let's include
the relevant albums in our collection of
item model objects here
notice that the item type property is
set to 2 for albums and the item type
property for items that represent movies
remains one
so the item type property in our example
distinguishes the types of items stored
in our collection on the server
if you don't feel like tapping out the
code like I'm doing here please feel
free to copy the relevant code from this
GitHub webpage
so the next step is to write code that
Imports the images for our albums into
our react application
so to do this let's first make a copy of
the movie images.js file
let's rename the copy of the movie
images.js file Album images dot Js
you can download these Album images from
this GitHub webpage
we can then copy the relevant downloaded
images
to a sensible location within our
projects
we can then appropriately modify our
album images.js file
so that the images that we have just
downloaded are appropriately imported
into our react application
excellent
so we want the user to be able to
navigate to the appropriate path where
the user can rank the albums
so let's first include an appropriate
route in the app Root array for this
purpose let's open the approot.js file
let's modify our code so that two
distinct routes are created
one route denotes a path relevant to
ranking movies The other route defines a
path relevant to ranking albums
both paths point to a component that we
are going to write in just a bit named
rank items container
this component will be the parent
component for the rank items component
for the rank movies path we want
specific prompt values to be passed down
to the rank items contain a component
for example the data type prop is
appropriately set to 1. now the date
type prop on the client is equivalent to
the item type property for an item that
we have added to a collection on the
server
so when this route is accessed the state
of our application is such that a user
can rank movies
a value of 2 is being passed down to the
rank items container for the rank album
path
so that the application will be in a
state where users can rank albums
the user will be able to put the
application in these states through
clicking the appropriate top menu items
on the UI we'll create the code for
these navigation menu items in just a
bit
if you are not clear on the significance
of the prop values we are passing down
to the rank items container component
for each root path don't worry this will
become clearer as we progress with the
development of this part of the
application
note that we are passing in the relevant
image arrays for each of the relevant
paths so we must write code to import
the relevant image arrays
let's open the file that denotes the nav
menu component and appropriately include
the relevant nav menu items
these items map to the appropriate parts
that we have defined within the
approot.js file
let's create a new file for our rank
items container.js functional component
in this part of the application we are
going to write code to store the state
of each collection of items one for
movies and one for albums in local
storage in the user's browser
so at the top we are creating two consts
one stores the local storage key for the
album collection and the other stores
the local storage key for the movie
collection
let's use the use State hook twice once
to track the state of the album
collection and the other for tracking
the state of the movie collection
So based on the dates type value passed
into this component we want to set
appropriate variables to the appropriate
collection and the function that is used
for changing the state of the relevant
collection
the local storage key variable is also
set based on the relevant data type
value
so this if condition is used for
altering the state of the application
based on the navigation menu item that
the user selects IE to rank movies or to
rank albums
so if the user selects the movies
navigation menu item the data type
variable will be set to 1. if the user
selects the album's navigation menu item
the data type variable will be set to 2.
a switch between these two values
appropriately changes the state of the
application
I.E for ranking movies or for ranking
albums depending on what the user wishes
to do
in The Return part of the rank items
container.js file
we can return the rank items component
that is being passed the appropriate
props
we must of course ensure that the rank
items component is appropriately
imported into the rank items container
component
let's write code to appropriately
destructure the relevant props
so we need to modify the use effect hook
code here so that the API is a
appropriately called when the data type
prop value changes
the change to the data type prop value
means that the user has clicked a
navigation menu item to Signal the
user's intention to rank items of a
different type to the type of items that
are currently being ranked or have just
been ranked so to do this instead of
empty square brackets being passed as
the second arguments to our use effect
hook we can pass in the data type
variable wrapped in square brackets
instead like this
we can also include another use effect
hook so that we can save the state of
the relevant collection to local storage
every time the relevant item collections
State changes in memory
we need to check if the relevant items
collection is null in the return code
here like this
note that we are no longer passing in an
empty array to the use State hook
so if the relevant items collection does
not exist in local storage the relevant
items collection will be null so the
array will be null
we also need to check to see if our
items collection is null before its new
state is written to local storage here
let's also abstract a call to the API
into its own function like this
we only want to call our API if the
items collection is null
so if the items collection is null call
the API to bring down the relevant items
collection from the server
it is a good idea to clear the items
from local storage before we test this
code
excellent we have now ranked two
different types of item sets movies
and albums
so a user may wish to clear the ranking
grid and start the whole ranking process
again during a session while ranking the
relevant items
so this clearing functionality would
involve removing all of the items from
the ranking grid and all items being
loaded back into the non-ranked items
list as it were
so let's implement the code for this by
providing a button that the user can
click to reset the items so that if
relevant items have been ranked these
items will have their ranking values set
back to zero
to do this we can force our components
to make an API call
to return the relevant items collection
to the client in its original state
where none of the items have been ranked
so let's add a button to The Return part
of the rank items component and let's
give our button the caption of reload
let's ensure that we are importing the
use State hook into this component so
two variables are returned from the use
statehook the first variable will be
used for storing a Boolean value
that when set to True means the user has
clicked the reload button meaning that
the user wishes to reload the relevant
items in their original unranked State
as discussed this button-click action
will force the rank items component to
make a call to the API to refresh the
items collection from the server
so let's Implement code whereby a call
is made to the API when the reload
variable State changes to true
we must also write code to set the
reload variable to false when the state
of the items collection changes
we can of course do this by calling the
set reload function appropriately like
this
let's make our reload button look a
little bit better
so let's go to this website find a CSS
style that we like for our button
and let's integrate the copied CSS code
you can copy the code simply by clicking
on one of the buttons here into our
application by including the relevant
CSS code in our custom.css file
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and I think that looks pretty great
I just want to make a quick Point Sharon
this is something that's very easy to
forget
you should always include a key
attribute for elements that are uniquely
identifiable in a list of elements this
helps react identify changes regarding
rendering the relevant component
[Music]
if you like this video please give this
video a thumbs up and please feel free
to share this video with anyone you feel
May benefit from its content
please also consider subscribing to the
channel and hit the Bell icon so that
you'll be notified of future content
I look forward to seeing you soon thank
you and take care